and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 148 today
we're gonna talk about breakups are you
breaking up with me
[Laughter]
540 episodes it 48 episodes in Ryan I
this is it man it's been fun but oh
thank god not that I don't love you I'm
just not in love with you that's fair
you know what's weird about oh by the
way we have Nate green with us today
hello I'll give it a proper intro to you
in a moment Nate there's something like
that cliche is actually so true really
is man like I'm not in love with you but
I still love you yeah and and it's just
like we need more words like like the N
you would have like a dozen words for
snow right to describe different types
of snow but we have this one word and
it's like love and yeah like it's such a
broad yeah it has a lot of meanings well
we are a lot of different inferences I
guess we took Ella our five year old
daughter to to ramen the other night or
are we first like Tatsu yeah Tatsu ramen
in West Hollywood and she's like I love
you and I love ramen because she's super
excited it's like her favorite
restaurant to go to and I'm trying to
explain to her like it's okay to love
ramen noodles like to enjoy that but
it's a different kind of love from
loving your parents or loving other
people it's a completely different thing
so hopefully we'll dive into that today
we're gonna talk about breaking up with
people so that that whole saying I I
love you but I'm not in love with you
like what does that mean to you it means
to me that I that I care about you I can
love you as a person but but I don't
want to I don't see a a partnership I
don't feel the way about you
romantically
that I otherwise would Nate what do you
think about that no I think it's really
a big thing like oh we're gonna get into
the into the the murky stuff of breaking
up here in a bit but I feel like it is
possible to still love someone deeply
and compassionately but for it to take a
different kind of form than a romantic
love yeah and I think that's what I'm
saying I don't feel like we need and I
know they're like different terms and
people are gonna start tweeting me it so
cop a love or whatever and what did you
say that there's a term agape love like
a brotherly love oh yeah and and so like
they're different they're different well
the terms but they're not commonly
accepted they even that I mean that is a
that's a different language
yeah that's not English it's I mean it's
a word we stole I don't know if it's a
Greek I think it's great yeah so it's
like yeah we even so we because we have
so few words for love and English
English language with to steal words
from other languages to describe the
love that were that we're dealing with
when I think about being in love with
some are I'm sorry loving someone but
not being in love with someone
uh-huh it's almost like I think of my
past relationships where I've just have
gotten into a routine of loving someone
and I don't know if either of you guys
have ever been in a relationship like
that where you start dating someone
things are really awesome the
chemistry's great
yeah chemistry's great and then six or
eight months into it you're like yeah I
still really like this person but you're
not as excited about it and then you
know maybe I know I certainly have done
this for like after a year it's like
wait a minute like I'm probably not
gonna marry this person mm-hmm but I'm
really used to having them in my life
and I really do love them as a person
but I'm not probably going to take this
you know that that next step or whatever
it may be I guess my point is is a lot
of the times we will stay in a
relationship yes because of the
familiarity with it and it's not even
the next step thing is interested me
because there doesn't necessarily have
to be a next step like I think about my
current relationship with with Beck's
and Ella like they're they're our next
steps in terms of evolving as a couple
but they're but it's wanting to continue
to journey down that same path
yeah and sometimes we keep going down
the same path even though you're like oh
I'm going down the wrong path and I
might be dragging this other person down
the wrong path as well yeah I'm and and
we're like both going down the wrong
path because we've refused to
acknowledge the fact that hey I can
still love you from a distance and
travel in a in a different path this is
the way that I look at it right now is a
how can I thank you for all the time
that we spent together and all the ways
that you have enriched my life um and
then not hold on to it anymore and the
love can still be present right you can
still you can still love someone and be
like thank you for everything that was
an amazing run I learned a lot from you
I'm feeling like I need to go this way I
get the sense that you need to go this
way let's have a conversation about that
and then figure out how to support each
other on these journeys because if you
built this love overtime there should be
a lot of communication and there should
be a lot of support still and then we
often feel compelled to sort of tear it
down if it mm-hmm I know in the past
I've been in relationships or where if
it hasn't worked out then all of a
sudden there's almost like this cultural
imperative to and it's so silly to me
now but there's a cultural imperative to
to shun the other person to tear them
down to make them feel bad in some way
because it didn't work out or maybe I
should feel bad that it didn't work out
as opposed to the other way to look at
it is you can also graduate from a
relationship it's what Dan Savage calls
the campsite rule right you want to
leave things better than you found them
at a campsite vaccinologist went camping
this past week and I'll have no part of
that look in there no no I
I'll avoid that but but I understand but
fundamentally I appreciate that rule
where it's like if you're going to be in
a relationship with someone whether
that's a business relationship a
friendship an acquaintance ship
networking whatever it is why not leave
that that relationship better than how
you found it I've I feel like the basis
for all of this is self love and then
communication about what you're feeling
and thinking with the other person in an
honest
'we like the only way that i feel like
you have a good relationship and the
only way that you have a good ending to
a relationship a romantic relationship
whatever is to be completely on board
and communicative with that person in a
direct and honest and open compassionate
way yeah and i think a lot of it has to
do with what you're just talking about
you being thanked for being grateful for
the time you had together and being able
to find a way to express that because
even if it relationships ending and even
if it's not your fault that it's ending
you can be grateful for that time that
you had together and you can still
express that in a way that that isn't
mopey or overly emotional or or
accusatory because there's there's
there's also a passive-aggressive a way
a passive-aggressive way to express your
gratitude yes and we want to avoid that
i've got a little bit of follow-up
before we dive into these questions
today someone a bunch of people on on
youtube avasta so I figure I just
finally address it because I attend I
don't respond to every youtube comment
although we read them and thankfully we
have a good YouTube audience it's not
the typical swine on on on YouTube we
have a really good people that genuinely
want to know why why do we stand on the
the podcast the entire time I like
standing because the alternative is to
sit the entire time and we do have
chairs so like we will sit from time to
time occasional if we're by the end of
this we do a postscript episode and if
my legs get tired I'm like I'd like to
sit a little bit I think this was a
Kelly Starrett and here's that book
about sitting is the new smoking yeah
and and this line stood out to me I
think it was from him where he talked
about what is your what's the best
position to work from is it sitting is
it standing and if it is sitting then
how should you sit if it's standing how
should you stand he said the next he
said the the best position is whatever
the next position is going to be always
move yeah always always be moving and so
that we don't get a whole lot of
opportunity that during the podcast cuz
we're you know a tethered to these these
mics here but when we're working in this
office space the other six days of the
week I will sit I will stand I'll move
around I'll I'll do squats you know I
find that just sitting there for eight
hours a day would be
worst thing to do the second worst thing
would be standing here for eight hours a
day that's not gonna be great for you
either so people wanted to know about
that also our last episode was episode
actually was two episodes ago 146 we did
an episode about curation and one thing
I didn't mention but Nate brought this
up Nate was staying over at our house
for a couple days the curated home he
was over at our house and he's like yeah
I love coming here because it it feels
really good like I feel calm in this
space yes and to me like that that's
that is the whole point of curation is
so so I I'm eliminating the the noise
the access so I can feel good wherever I
am it's the reason that that museums
elicit a particular feeling from you
that's part of the experience we did
talk about that on the podcast like if
you took all the beautiful art at at the
MoMA or LACMA and you just shoved it
into a storage locker it's still
beautiful art but it would totally ruin
whelming yeah yeah you wouldn't be able
to handle it well dude if you went to a
museum and they just had like you know
what the like super centers they've got
the posters where you can like flip
through the posters I'm like could you
imagine if it was just like one room and
you just sit there and flip through a
bunch of art and then you left like it
would be and I think it's the same same
with our homes is being able to to come
home and feel that sense of calm knowing
that that I've curated a space that
feels good to me and it's something I
look forward going back to as opposed to
the opposite like I can't believe I
gotta go home I have to deal with this I
feel like the mental clarity kind of
starts with physical space right like
not that I need everything to be exactly
in its place in order for me to function
but I know I feel my best when my
physical space feels calm and refreshing
and just good to be and so when I walk
into your home I have this like feeling
where I'm like I feel it's not even my
home but I feel home yeah and that I
think that's beautiful thank you for
saying it I mean I don't curate it for
other people if we very rarely he'll do
that for me but but it's nice that that
and what what we're talking about here
is there are some universals when we get
rid of that excess because the opposite
I think of the TV show hoarders I mean
clearly there's a lot
mental illness there so if you go one or
two steps below that just a really
cluttered house there is a sense of
chaos that you can very easily deal with
because that that external clutter is an
external expression of what's going on
inside and and clearing that excess for
me has enabled me to better deal with
what's what's going on side
it's curating the exterior so I can
curate my interior and whether that's
through through meditation or it is
through just walking exercise just
different activities that allow me to
have a better sort of internal state
really helpful curating my life means
not just the physical stuff but curating
me as a person as well yeah well a well
curated exterior is a symptom of a well
curated interior listen that you could
tweet that put that as a minimal
maximally we do this thing during the
lightning round you see we have these in
the shownotes podcast Shaun puts the
anything pithy we say that's like
tweetable he puts it in the show notes
they're called minimal Maxim's and then
Jessica who does our social media she
she has a separate website called
minimal Maxim's calm or isn't all the
pithy things that Ryan and I have said
over the last eight years or sort of
catalog evilly or you think that way now
no no I I see it I'm like man that is a
profound quote and then all of a sudden
I realize someone like quoted us because
here's the thing if you monitor on
enough there's a that you have a ton of
sediment on this table eventually you
might find a little nugget of gold and
and so jess is the one who does the
panning for gold it's like you have your
best thoughts ever captured in a
specific location that way you can just
go back and revisit them from time to
time and then you feel good about
yourself well it's also like taking your
own advice is the hardest pill to
swallow yeah absolutely
and so I can go back and say okay like
that is really good advice now maybe if
I go and I'll go to mineral Maxim's you
just hit refresh and a new one pops up
each time and so I'll just find more and
I'm like yeah that that's really good it
could be from me or could be from Ryan
I'm like that's something I noticed in
my life but I should do more in my I
forget where I heard this but I think
the quote was something like the advice
that you most often give is
the advice that you need to take yes and
then will Maxim right there yeah yeah
that's a good one shot so so I it was
true I think that's why Ryan and I have
talked about minimalism for the last
eight years because we still struggle
with consumerism right and and and
making sure we can stave that off now
Nate how did we meet by the way we we
don't do interviews on this this podcast
but occasionally bring some friends on
yes to to answer some questions we'll
get to those questions here momentarily
but we met in an interesting way
yeah we met in a coffee shop I don't
know if you know this actually the first
time I met Ryan I paid him nearly as
interesting is how Nate and I met yeah
every word it was dark no oh no I don't
ever do bridge pizza man yeah we met at
bridge pizza and Montana yeah I have
this I have this thing man like I really
feel like if you want to get to know
someone you have to kind of break
through the noise and you have to be
respectful so I take my work very
seriously I know you do too and so I was
like I think I want to meet these guys
the minimalists I've been following your
blog for a while and so I was like how
can I do that in a way that feels good
and so I did a mentorship session with
Ryan just one-off and we met at bridge
pizza and hung out and I thought it was
great I was like cool Ryan hanging out
with Nate and I was like man this guy's
got a [ __ ] together why's he pay me and
I met you I kept seeing you cuz we all
lived in Mizzou Missoula at the time and
it's a small place so and you and I I
feel like have similar tastes we just
ran into each other all the time at the
same places mostly coffee shops right
and I think I bought you a $50 gift card
just zoo Town brew and I and I left it
there with them and I think I wrote you
a note but I don't do not remember what
it said you did okay and I think the
note was like just really simple like
hey I appreciate the work that you're
doing yeah you know thanks for what
you're putting out into the world yes
yeah and so apparently you uh you found
that cool and
you we talked like the next time yeah
next time I saw it
yeah and then you invited me to the
sauna yeah and then I think the first
time we really hung out like we were at
the YMCA sweating together in a sauna
this is like the most random friendship
of all time what's our other green
friend dr. Ryan angry he talks about how
like the people who sweat together grow
together yeah and I that that's sort of
an exercise maximum for him but it's
also with the song like we went to the
Russian bathhouse with dr. Greene this
weekend I'm going back there that was
amazed a few other friends it was so
good but like there's something about
that where were you're able to connect
and it's part of its getting yourself
outside of a a comfort zone and into
enough into a discomfort zone that it's
not painful but but it's it's a
different experience that you're both
having so it becomes memorable and thus
it becomes meaningful yes so so Nate
you're you're a writer among other
things going to be a world traveler
again very soon yes if folks want to
check out your work it's Nate Greene or
where you're on Twitter yours at Nate
Greene
it's the Nate Ghana yeah I know it
sounds a little conceited but there were
already so many Nate Greene yeah good
putting the work in front of it would
work and it totally worked alright well
check them out there and then we'll talk
more about our stories let's dive into
some of these these questions Kristiana
from parts unknown I'm not sure where
she's from Sean so I just have parts
unknown she has the first question for
us how do I move on from a relationship
and still be friends with that person
man Nate I'm really looking like I when
I heard this question I'm looking
forward to what you have to say because
I know that this is so important for you
after going going through this breakup
absolutely with your ex yeah yeah it's
it's like I think about my past
relationships and how I was able to stay
friends with my exes while I didn't yeah
I did a really good job of burning all
of my bridges with my accident name that
we're talking about that this weekend
where I was going to say Ryan and I have
similar perspectives now but we had
totally different paths to get there
yeah we're I'm friends with almost
everyone who I've had an intimate
relationship with and like we still keep
in contact in fact really good friends
with some of them
and there are a couple outliers which we
can certainly talk about as well but an
Orion has a different scenario now I
know if you and Mariah were to move on
from each other I don't even know so
their breakup is the wrong word for what
you you went through with your former
partner and that's the other thing that
I try to distinguish the language is
important yeah actually I picked that up
from you because so for people that
don't know which is everyone I was
together with a wonderful beautiful
woman for 10 years in almost 10 years
and then we had a this term is kind of
weird but a conscious uncoupling right
that's what celebrities do apparently
and I just feel like I'm gonna steal
their language because it feels more
appropriate than calling it a breakup
right and so I don't call it the word I
would use is graduation almost yeah I
know I've used it a couple times but
like high school can be a great
experience but sometimes you have to
move on from that you don't want to live
and I think about the term breakup that
means that yes something is broken
yes yeah yeah you want to let your
trying to like split from this
relationship breaking as little things
as my learn we were not broken people
right we were whole in our own ways
right and then this this just was the
next logical step and continuation of
the relationship was to end it
romantically and figure out and and it's
still it's it's new it's fresh it's a
month and a half when we when we decided
to see even now even now I struggle with
the language like split whatever right
yeah we decided not to be together
anymore right we really is changing the
relationship that's that's what your
Siana is talking about here it's it's
not about breakup so much as it is the
relationship was one thing before how do
I move forward to make it another thing
it's a transformation yeah and I think
the first thing is changing the language
that we're using so instead of these
negative words like breakup or ex I
using positive language that helps us re
identify what this relationship is going
to look like I can say my friend Randy
or my friend Colleen or my friend
whomever without saying you know my ex
yeah I can say here are here's a friend
that we may have once had that type of
relation but that that is less relevant
now
to our current relationship whether or
not we had that an intimate relationship
previously what does the relationship
look like now and how do i how do i
foster that the other thing that that
I'll say and I think you're discovering
this right now and they maybe you can
talk about some of the events that
because I know was it was a there was a
long road and and maybe you were in a
way dealing with the uncoupling for a
longer period of time then then she was
because well can you talk a little bit
about how you any of the events that led
up to it absolutely and this is a this
is a fun and kind of vulnerable place to
be because I I feel so good about it at
the same time it's like obviously I want
to be incredibly respectful to her so I
probably won't get into like a bunch of
like the nitty-gritty details but I can
tell you how we got to where we are so
they're together for 10 years and we
worked a lot on our communication like
are really I mean you know we stayed
with you a couple months ago actually
and we prided ourselves and always
telling each other what we were feeling
when it needed to be said and we built
up this relationship of love and
compassion and joint work together like
we worked in the same kind of industry
doing the same kind of work we would
introduce each other to each other's
friends so it was a beautiful thing but
it reached a point where so the way that
the way that she framed it for me was
really helpful she said we sat on the
couch had a 3-hour long conversation
I honestly did not see this coming at
the time so she she you and I had
conversations maybe six months prior yes
I didn't see the breakup coming but I
knew the word breakup yeah I I didn't
see that coming but I guess it was
always in the back of my head as a
possibility like we talked about it like
if we were to not be together anymore
what would we do it these are
conversations that we had all throughout
our relationship this is how we would
split up finances this is how if we
lived together for eight or nine of
those years out of ten so we just had
this constant communication of this is
how we would uncouple if it ever gets to
that
so when it finally happened and we sat
on the couch and she said I feel like I
have one foot in and one foot out of the
relationship and I feel like you Nate
have two feet in and I've been feeling
it for the last six months or so and
it's not fair to you and it's not fair
to me and when she said that something
just kind of opened up in me and I felt
not anger not upset not anything like
that I felt so much love and compassion
for her that she trusted me that much
that she could be that honest and direct
with me and so we had this beautiful
conversation that lasted a few hours
where we talked about all the amazing
things that we had accomplished together
all the difficult things and then what
this was going to look like moving
forward and like that night she left to
go to a friend's house and I stayed and
then a couple days later and this was
them this was the most difficult part of
this a couple days later I we had
another conversation she came to the
house and we sat in her car and we
talked for maybe half an hour and she
thought maybe we made the wrong decision
and we had a decision to make at that
point right - like negate the three hour
long conversation we had where we were
probably the most open honest egoless
not defensive place we ever have been or
go back and try to start this thing up
again right and so I just had this
moment of clarity where it just became
very clear to me where where I thought
are we here right now sitting here
talking about maybe getting back
together are we here out of love or are
we here out of fear because if we're
here out of love maybe it's worth making
it work but if we can both be honest
with ourselves and say why am I having
this conversation right now am I afraid
of course I never want to do anything
precious and important out of fear I
only want to go toward love right so
that's so then we we had that
conversation
there was like a moment of silence like
quite literally in the car and we
decided no this is the right decision
and so that was a month and a half ago
and since then we are gonna continue to
be friends but we need some physical
space right now like Missoula is a small
town so I'm getting ready to move to
Thailand for six months and since I'm a
writer I can kind of go wherever go live
in Europe but I've seen her a couple of
times because we have all the things
that you have to do we had a joint bank
accounts we had a dog together we have
all this stuff that we I mean not a lot
of stuff but you know we had stuff that
we needed you had a life together we had
a library other that we needed to divvy
up and figure out how does how does this
work but right now I can't say that we
are gonna be great friends but I think
we're on that path because the last time
that we talked to each other we talked
about the other people that were kind of
seeing right now we acknowledged that
that's a thing we talked about how much
we still loved and cared for each other
and how we think this is gonna be
amazing in the future but right now we
need some physical space because an
emotional space because think about it
like after ten years in a relationship
you get to a point where it just becomes
habitual and natural if I sit next to
her my first inclination is to put my
hand on her leg right not that I'm
trying to manipulate or do anything it's
just the habit her in 10 years yeah and
so yeah I feel like right now we're in a
good position where I support her
she supports me completely and I know I
would love to continue to be great
friends with her and I think that's
possible but it's still early stages but
I I feel really good about it
there's a time of you have to stop being
communicative for a while as that
relationship changes right because it's
hard the it's not an easy transition as
yesterday we were lovers today we're
friends know there is that space in
between and that space is being less
expressive with the other person because
you had this beautiful moment of of true
expression and it's what our friend
Colin right calls the I'll tell you
policy like he has a great book called
some thoughts about relationships it's
it's not just my favorite Colin book but
it's my favorite book about
relationships period it these little
pithy sort of policies that he has about
any relationship that he enters into
intimate or otherwise and one is the
I'll tell you policy that's the one that
I've used most in my current
relationship to make it thrive in fact
when something's not going well
Beck's will come to me and say well you
didn't honor the I'll tell you policy
that's gay and that kind of
accountability hold each other
accountable for that in fact he did this
with me just the other day and and it
can it's it's usually with small stuff
because even with the small things those
things confessed her and then resentment
builds right if we're not being
completely forthright and what you had
was this three hour I'll tell you like
like but Allen's battle royal right like
here's a lot of things that we haven't
maybe stuck to the full I'll tell you up
until this point because she had one
foot out for six months yeah
and and for whatever reason maybe she
felt like she couldn't talk to you about
it maybe she felt like you weren't
providing the space for her to talk
about it
maybe she just wasn't ready to talk
about it but sometimes before we're even
ready we need to say it doesn't mean we
just need to vomit up every little
thought that we have in fact that that
can be detrimental but if something is
going on we usually know but the nice
thing about that is Bex and I very
rarely go to each other now say is
everything okay oh yeah no because that
happens all the time in other
relationships that I've had you sure
everything's okay like I can see it on
your features you're hiding something
and and maybe you're wanting me to ask
you that question so you can open it up
you don't have to wait for me to say is
everything okay - tell me what's what's
going on I feel like at that point if
you're if you're consistently asking
your partner like is everything okay you
sure like there is a deeper thing that's
happening there where you don't have
good communication right like if you're
always wondering and worrying what the
other person is feeling thinking and you
read into every single situation or
facial expression or lack of comment or
whatever yeah I feel like you're in a
position where you need to have that
couple hour long conversation on the
couch and say like where where are we at
and like here's what I promise to do for
you and for myself which is to always be
honest and direct
you how I'm feeling when it when I feel
it it's appropriate yeah that
communication it could be an error on
both sides meaning yes like there's
obviously communication or some partners
and my partner isn't willing to tell me
what's wrong but also someone who asked
that question a lot there might be
something wrong with themselves like
that they might be
themselves holding back some information
absolutely - - biggest thing that stand
out to me right now from this
conversation is you said something about
respect and how that is how you and your
ex are able or your current friend but
but you know you you you mentioned
respect and how important that is for
for you guys to maintain this friendship
and you talked about the the the break
that you have to have before you can
even really go out of your way to like
show support and respect for one another
a distance right and then in the
distance like that has to be created
because you know to your point like yeah
you had ten years of these patterns that
you developed with your partner and yeah
you can't just flip a switch and have
those go off you have to have some time
in order to let that stuff settle down
and be able to come at the relationship
with a different approach I think you
have to be willing to feel your feelings
completely because I think if you're
able I don't think anyone is able to
flip the switch just like that and go
from like romantic partnership to just
friends and a day now that may not be
true there may be people like that out
there
yes we're called sociopaths yes josh is
the highest functioning sociopath I know
yeah I totally lost my train of thought
I'm sorry bring it back here so the
thing that Ryan was talking about that I
think relates to this is a metaphor so
you have a record you know then the one
over 12-inch record right sure and and
you put on a record player and it plays
the same song on every single time and
that's what's happened you get you have
you've built these grooves up in your
relationship with your former partner
and those grooves are going to be there
and the only way to change that is to
take the record and do something to
the record now you can do it relatively
quickly by you know scratching the hell
out of it or sanding down the surface
but that is going to change that pattern
and I think for us this the sandpaper
here is just time there could be other
things as well like having new
relationships exposing yourself to two
different people going out and dating
finding new friends new geography can be
really helpful solutely I look at it as
a kind of I mean I'm in a fortunate
position where I can I kind of look at
as a grand gesture right like how can I
go do something that is so unlike what
I've been doing for the last few years
so I'm planning on this trip to Thailand
for six months and then maybe continuing
to Europe for a bit and I'm fortunate
that I can work while on the road but
this the geographical change and the the
new cultures all experience because of
that and that all the new people all
meet like this is a very like I think
it's gonna be a salv almost like I'm
excited for like I don't I don't feel
like I need to be healed or anything I
feel really good and hold right now but
I think it's gonna get me out of my
comfort zone in some way and at the same
time opened me up to new experiences
which just become great stories and ways
to connect with other people yeah yeah
the thing that I think about with
respect to if you want to be friends
with this person long-term the questions
I have to ask myself is were we friends
before yes that's huge because if it
maybe maybe you weren't I've been an
I've been in romantic relationship so
the relationships that I'm not still
friends with people from before there
are people who I wasn't actual I there
was a sexual attraction some sort of
chemistry like I wanted to date this
person but I didn't necessarily want to
be their friend but if it wasn't for the
sex yeah we wouldn't have been friends
right yeah and so like it was the wrong
reason to get into that type of
relationship and not knocking anyone who
wants to go out and and and and just
have one-night stands or whatever but
that's not a that's not something for me
but also that's not a friendship you
can't just go out have a bunch of one I
stand to call those people friends
that's not what that is that is
transactional and that could be fun if
there's two consenting parties there but
but for me I think of
the people who I'm still friends with
now in fact when I first met Beck's and
she had just gotten out of a marriage
and was not ready to be in any sort of
long-term relationship and I knew for a
fact that I didn't want to be in a
long-term relationship for a long time
if ever and although we met each other
and it was like it was so ideal and I
felt really good and she asked me like
what are your intentions here like what
do you want are you just are you trying
to hook up or are you you trying to date
well what do you I said hey I don't know
what the future holds but it'd be great
if we could just be friends first hmm
and the reason that I want to put that
out there was twofold and I told her
this I said if if we're friends right
now and that works out then that's great
and if we were just friends in
perpetuity then great I've made a new
friend
yeah if it goes beyond friendship
because I find you attractive and
apparently you say you find me
attractive so great if it goes beyond
that then that's great too because if
there ever is a future uncoupling then
that potential that foundation we've
built is built on a friendship first and
it seems to me like you and your former
partner you were really good friends I
mean I I hung out with both of you quite
a bit yeah and it seems like you were
good friends so I still see I see the
potential of a friendship in the future
once that that record has been sanded
down and I think the one thing that kind
of contributed to us not being involved
romantically anymore is we became such
good friends that I feel like the
boundaries started to dissolve a little
bit and not that not that we weren't
sexual at all and not that we didn't put
a lot of attention into that part of our
lives because we did and it was a great
part of our relationship but I feel like
we both at a certain point realized that
I just want to hang out with you like we
could still have sex too but I want to
hang out with you like I'm more
interested in talking with you and
learning about you and helping you
becoming unbalanced yeah a little bit
right and but if you would have asked me
in the moment do I feel that way I
wouldn't have
able to conjure that up I was not it was
not on the the screen of my mind it's a
thing that was happening and so it's
only been after the last month and a
half of you know having this retrospect
and being able to look back where I can
start to see like you said little cracks
and I can see how we got here but I
still feel really good about it
like I don't look back at anything and
go I wish I would have done that
differently I'm like no this is exactly
what should have happened because this
is just the path we were on and it makes
sense I feel like this is another reason
why it's so important to take space it's
because it gives you some time to like
look back at the relationship yes and
like really kind of dissect it a little
bit I mean you don't want to over
analyze it but yeah you don't have to
ruminate it out but you can't look back
because I know for me the reason my my
relationship with vex so great the
reason your relationship with mariah is
so great is because we have learned a
lot of lessons in the past and you can
choose to do I've screwed up so many
relationships to get good at this one
flower I do actually want to talk about
that but there's a our friend drew from
parlor hawk he has his gray line he said
I learned a lot of good lessons here
that I choose to forget mmm I think
that's what we do sometimes like I
learned a really great lesson from this
relationship but [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
not pay attention to that lesson I'm
gonna do the same destructive behavior
in the next one and the next one in the
next one is it's easier because it's not
yeah but I think we also trick ourselves
and say it's not my fault it's everyone
else's fault yeah now Ryan that there
are also cases and you alluded this a
moment ago something so crystianna's
question is how do I move on from a
relationship and still be friends
sometimes you can't right absolutely
well yeah first and foremost you have to
you have to get click I wrote down like
you know here are a few things but the
first thing I wrote down is make sure
that they're interested in still being
friends make sure that you're interested
in still being from exactly like if both
parties are not interested in the
friendship but then well then that's
that's where you might not want to try
and be friends still yeah yeah I mean
you can track someone kicking and
screaming toward friendship right that
that never works right that's at best
that's indentured servitude and and so
yeah but but maybe talk about if you're
willing to talk a little bit about some
past relationships like where those
lessons that you learned that you chose
to forget but the land looking back and
were you like of course we can't be
friends now but
what lessons did you learn from those
relationships where maybe some longer
term relationships or mid term
relationships yeah no I I think like my
biggest issues with past relationships
was honesty it was it was just not being
honest with the other person I was
really bad at like cheating on all my
exes
the one long relationship I had where I
was like completely faithful I think
that broke down because I was well after
like eight months to a year of us dating
I remember thinking like oh man like I
don't think this is gonna work mainly
was because of like where I was working
versus where she lived and she had a kid
and wasn't willing to move from there
and it was like this two and a half hour
drive from each way yeah each way Wow so
I'm like oh man like this just this
probably isn't gonna work but I was so
invested in her family I was so like I
mean if out of the whole relationship
the best thing about that relationship
was her family what a mistake I mean I
had the same thing with the person I I
dated before backs I mean I absolutely I
think she's great where I were actually
still friends but one of the things that
really stood out was like man I'd
realize this relation because I get
along with her dad really well and that
familiarity like it's just it's it's
very scary to leave it I so it and I was
just thinking like going with the you
know going towards fear going towards
love like I stayed in that relationship
for an additional three years Oh out of
fear out of fear from from leaving when
I was so comfortable with I'm sorry what
we gonna say oh no no I'm the one
interrupting you know I just just on
that point it was I actually had a
wonderful two-hour lunch with my former
partners parents yeah and they said
whenever you're in town we'd love for
you to stay with us so we love you we
think of you as a son thank you for
everything that you've done for our
family and I look at that as like my
second set of parents right now which is
very surreal and random and weird and
beautiful and so I think you can like if
you can leave a relationship and still
be friends you can still be friends with
the other people yeah relationship right
I love that example I'll say the other
thing to men is
like I did not like all the exes that I
can think of very few of well I should
say pre like pre the minimalists talking
like 2000 Lee had you know at the
beginning of the show I said oh I'm not
friends with any of my exes there are
certainly some exes that I have like
it's it's definitely fewer exes I'm
friends with than not friends with so I
have been able to salvage some of the
relationships but I guess what I'm
getting at is is that early on like
after I got divorced I took the dating
approach of like oh yes I'm going to
have this sexual attraction to this
woman we're gonna have a really good
sexual chemistry and and we're going to
you know be together for however long
and never ever considered whether or not
we would actually be friends in real
life and like any of the exes that I
have like I treated as I don't know dude
like oh oh honey I'm gonna I'm gonna be
gone this weekend because I'm gonna have
to have a guys night out of it I gotta
go be with my friends like that is like
hindsight that is a really like if
that's happening in the relationship
that's kind of to me it's an Ordnung
sign maybe a little bit ya know it's
okay to have guys it's okay to just have
a guy time don't get me wrong I'm not
doubting guy time all right good I was
gonna say that though just to pull it
apart the thread a little bit because it
is important to be able to have your own
quote/unquote circle of friends and to
be able to spend time alone and to feel
very very comfortable in that space yes
um but it seems like what you're saying
isn't it's not like guy time or alone
time isn't important it's an escape from
the relationship exactly yeah that's
what I wanted to get to yeah well you
know I don't and by the way I I'm gonna
disagree a little bit about yes it is
okay to have guy time but if I'm dating
someone who I couldn't bring around my
male friends yes yeah that's a problem
that would definitely be a problem right
yeah no night is only people with y
chromosomes you're not invited yeah but
yeah yeah I think we're on the same page
I mean there are there are times where
with mer I'm like yeah I'm gonna go out
to lunch with Josh uh-huh and I wanted
to just be Josh and I because like and I
haven't hung out by ourselves yet but
but
nothing to do with us having to
y-chromosomes in fact we want to hang
out together by the way I'm way better
one-on-one than I am with with a group
of people and so me being around four
people five people whatever is is way
more difficult for me than just sitting
one-on-one with you like yeah it's a
much better interaction yeah so so we've
got to two points like your what you're
saying mentally is that if you've got a
partner who you can't bring around a
certain group of friends like that's
gonna be an issue if it's not an issue
today it's gonna be an issue tomorrow if
it ain't tomorrow it's gonna be a year
from now he'll semester so forth and so
on and then what you're saying Nate is
that yes it's okay to go out and like
have some alone time and be independent
but if someone finds themselves escaping
from the relationship like finding
excuses to not be around that person to
escape like that is also a warning sighs
I totally agree throw one more thing in
here then we'll move on to the next
question I do find myself escaping now
but it's because of my introversion it's
not escaping from the relationship it's
escaping from people in general and and
being able to although with this new
diet that I've been doing I've been able
to be more extroverted I've had more
energy to to to just be around people
more which has been has been great but
even still it's instead of 90 percent of
my time alone it's 80 percent of my time
alone and and that makes me better when
I'm around other people it's not
escaping the individual it's escape it's
like hey it's not you it's me literally
like I mean that like hey it's me I need
my alone time so I can be a better
version of myself when I am around you I
don't wouldn't even look at it as
escaping though man I would look at it
as like a recharging it's it's love
yourself first to be able to love other
people right yeah oh yeah yeah so I
think there are are seven different
types of relationships we can go through
them really quickly and when we talk
about relationships we all we often
think of our relationship with people
like relationships of course that means
interpersonal relationships right I
think that's the final type of
relationship I think before you get
there you have the relationship with the
truth so so Ryan you just talked about
that Lea the the biggest reason that
past relationships didn't work for you
is because of your relationship with the
truth at the time
and realizing that doesn't mean you're a
dishonest person it means you're a
person who's able to fix that right
because I've had the same exact thing
happened to me and I think we all have
had a rocky relationship with the truth
at some point in time so fixing the
relationship with the truth
the second relationship is our
relationship with like stuff
quite often we're we're we're loving
commodities and then we're commodifying
the people we love and and and treating
the people like it's a transaction or
treating them you know it's the same
thing I love ramen and I love you
yeah we're commodifying our
relationships and we're treating people
with the same thing as stuff and and
that's the thing you and I obviously
always talk about is is dealing with the
stuff not that's not the end result that
is merely the first step so we can clear
the clutter to make room for what's
truly important I think the third
relationship is what you're talking
about there it's a relationship with
self being able to love myself and
that's one thing that I've struggled
with with the most is it's personally
like feeling inadequate because I'm
introverted or because I mean I have a
particular you know skill center or
talent or whatever or just my
attractiveness like because I was fat
for most of my life you know wait eighty
pounds more than I weigh and so for all
of my developing years and teenage years
like I dealt with like problems with my
own self loan and and that has carried
forward obviously into adult those scars
are still there I'm still a negative
that's however quiet still there yeah
for things a relationship with money
like that the the the the two reasons
that people break up is money in sex
those are the two big ones right now
yours is obviously different yeah your
own and but it's it's over 80% of
relationships because of money or sex or
both right
III think the fifth one it has to do
with with creativity and so quite often
we we we turn to all this like
additional sort of consumption because
we are we're scared to be that
vulnerable person who's creating and and
so we're we're unhappy with our careers
were unhappy with what
putting into the world and doesn't feel
meaningful so we turned to these other
sort of pacifiers these other
indiscretions these these these bad
habits because we're afraid of failure
right and afraid of what we're going to
create eventually what will get the
people but but but really I think it's
it's fixing these these these sort of
core relationships in our lives so we
can fix the the ultimate relationships
which is our connectivity with other
people and interdependence yeah yeah
yeah because the problem is when you try
to just I'm just gonna fix my personal
relationships but all this other stuff
I'm I'm gonna but I'm gonna keep lying
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna keep treating
people like commodities I'm gonna keep
putting money first I'm going to not not
be creative I'm not going to to put
myself for able to sit alone in a room
yeah yeah when we have when we have
these sort of issues we're not
addressing me I think it's it's a soup
right and like you know you have one bad
ingredient it ruins the it ruins the
whole soup and so ultimately we're
talking about these breakups we're
really talking about what's everything
else that's under the surface so what
was the sixth one relationship with sex
no so so it was money what was after
money let's go through them again here
truth me a truth first and then we've
done self stuff self money money
Oh values is the fifth one so getting
really clear on what your what your
values are because that's the other
thing we're and then the sixth one was
creativity right so values are like yeah
I think there are four different types
of values and we can go back to episode
69 of our podcast and we we had a
two-hour dissertation on on all the
different values that that we have but
what often we get into relationship with
someone like Ryan so because like the
chemistry was there and like this is
great sex but none of our values are the
same so we're going in different places
and so she's either dragging me or I'm
dragging her toward my values and that
never works because it's just this pool
this constant pool in this there's
tension but it's not a good tension it's
an over extension and so getting clear
on what your values are so that you can
be in a relationship with people who
have the same values values even if they
have different beliefs they have
different
they have different interest they have
different personalities all that stuff
is great as long as you're headed in the
same direction with your value different
doorways to the same values yeah you can
get there through different ways and
different means yeah I tend to look at
your beliefs so so we Ryan I often talk
about following your values and and
doing what aligns with your values and
your beliefs your values like Ryan I
have the same values we have pretty
different beliefs on a lot of different
things political beliefs spiritual
beliefs we have different paths to get
to that same destination
yeah blowdryer beliefs the one thing I
want to just say before we move on in
the next question the last thing I when
I had is if there's any jealousy at all
mmm like jealousy is a surefire way to
kill any whether it's a friendship or a
romantic relationship yeah
like especially projecting that jealousy
like that is a surefire way it's a
killer relationship so when I think
about my past breakups one of the main
reasons why I couldn't stay friends with
those people is because of jealousy like
I wouldn't be able to see them I
wouldn't be able to see them you know
date another person like I just wouldn't
I wasn't mature enough to not be jealous
it's total wasted emotion it really is
it has no productive value from it that
that jealousy in fact it is the opposite
of productive it keeps you from being
friends with that person well and just
to go back to what we're talking about
earlier like that is a fear-based
emotion yeah right jealousy is fear and
if you're operating from that system
it's not gonna turn out well for you
yeah there are there are legitimate
times where fear is useful but very
rarely our friend Julian Smith wrote a
book a long time ago called the flinch
did you ever read the bunch it's super
short it's like 30 pages and it's on a
Kindle but he talks about how we as
humans develop this fear to like a
literal Flynn check if you swing at me
I'm gonna flinch like yeah I'm
protecting myself right or if you're out
in the wild and the Tigers getting ready
to pounce on you you're going to flinch
but now like my 401 K did point one
percent this month flinch I'm gonna
flinch yeah and we start flinching all
of these things we shouldn't be
flinching at and we're building up this
this sort of fear I don't know if likes
on my facebook posts yeah I mean what
what so-and-so didn't like it yeah
and in jealousy is that type of flinch
it's not actually useful it's it's
taking this thing that was once useful
this fear and and and totally using it
in a useless way in fact a
counterproductive way what's interesting
though is that you can still be like
it's still a natural human emotion and
it's still something that you can see
and embrace and then just decide what to
do with it afterwards absolutely you're
not gonna not feel jealousy at some
point right but you can decide how to go
through with like the next step yeah
like you can look at jealousy like maybe
it's an indicator mm-hmm like if I'm gel
like if we're at the Russian bathhouse
and like you know you're supporting your
six-pack yeah I'm like look into the
mirror and I'm like Nate with his so
jealous and Nate six I mean to me that's
an indicator of what Ryan I've got to
focus on diet and exercise so yeah I
totally agree man like you can take the
the jealous emotion and maybe maybe not
making a positive as much as you can use
it as it yeah use it as a tool to make
some impactful check it can be a
catalyst for change and so I think quite
often that that's the thing we can take
these things we can we can see it's an
indicator that I need to need to make
some sort of change if I if I stew in
this jealousy it's going to continue to
be powder counterproductive but if I if
I find a different emotion like now I
feel motivated I feel inspired that's a
totally different emotion I feel like
with with a relationship that didn't
work out in the past and and if someone
was like if I see them with someone else
I'm like okay I need to be a better
version of myself if I want my next
relationship to work out and here's the
thing that I want to say about this too
is a this is all hard work yeah do those
kind of stuff like this is not I mean
maybe it comes naturally to sociopaths
but this is a hard work it's much it's
hard work for me it's humbling it's like
it's like you have to be honest with
yourself it takes a lot of like I got to
give in to pride
yeah why I've given it a pride so much
over the past you know eight ten years
that like now it's kind of set like
maybe I don't stand up for myself enough
at this point cuz like I give into it so
much but but I totally agree man like
it's a lot of work and part of that work
is like going at what basically you know
kind of put your pride aside it's work
worth doing but I just like it does
come easily for anybody I don't think
well I think also when you stand up for
yourself now though because you don't
feel that impulse to like you know a guy
at a bar like who why is he looking at
me right you you you you because that's
a different kind of I'm standing up for
myself even when I don't need to stand
up for myself but now when you do it
it's more effective it's more
influential as well because the the the
person who rarely speaks is the person
who can often be heard the most remember
I remember we were sitting down and I
we're at the bath spa and I had a little
Maxim for him a friend of mine Michel de
Santi I was hanging out with him and I
love the way that he carries himself he
just it seems as if he speaks only when
he has something to say and I'm very
gregarious so I talk all the time but I
asked him I'm like how do you choose
like when to talk and he sat there for
like a minute and thought and he said I
try to only speak when I have something
more valuable to say than silence mmm oh
look at his face right now that's good
so Josh just came on the microphone
alright with that said another question
is from Danielle in Kentucky cool what's
the best way to move on and get rid of
old memories from somebody who left a
relationship where it ended without any
information a good thing so if this
person just like stopped talking to
Danielle then technically they're still
together right this isn't a breakup
question is how that works that's that's
a plot of a crazy probably gonna be live
thinking they still have a relation
we're still married 30 years later I saw
this tweet where this girl was like hey
to Jimmy who asked me out in the first
grade and I said yes to we never
officially broke up
happy 15 year anniversary I mean I I
don't take her question seriously though
with three things yes how do I move on
how do I get rid of old memories and
then how I deal with this ghosting as
well I've actually had this happen to me
once hmm
was someone really loved really cared
about
and the first thing that I had to
realize it was our friend Colin Wright
who talked to me about this talked me
off the ledge so to speak was you aren't
owed anything mmm maybe maybe you feel
like you're in the right and maybe you
are in the right yeah you're not old
you're not entitled yeah yeah you you
aren't you
you aren't owed a response you aren't
owed a text back you aren't over the
phone call back you aren't owed an
explanation you know what it might be a
real [ __ ] thing for them to not
respond to you to not call you back to
not give you that explanation mm-hmm but
remember that you're not owed that and
you know what Danielle it sucks and I'm
sorry you have to go through it because
I would prefer the opposite you you got
some sort of because we right right now
I think the real question here the
implicit question is how do I get some
closure right on this enclosure is
important yeah and so so how do you move
on well you move on by all the things we
just talked about before clearly there's
no friendship here on the horizon or so
you think
who knows there may be enough time that
goes by and and this other person he'll
just say you know what he might reach
out to a year from the house was a real
just a real jerk I was going through
these three things in my life and my
sister was being mean to me and my mom
disowned me because of my religion or
whatever like like you realize like oh
this person is fighting their own
battles and I'm part of that this this
their overall war right this is only one
battle and maybe the best way that they
can deal with it right now is by by not
acknowledging your existence and that
sucks because but you know what sucks
suck even more is if they lashed out at
you they were mean to you that they or
worse obviously if they were they were
violent or did something illegal I mean
abusive and in any way that would be
much worse and and maybe this is even a
type of abuse it's a psychological or
emotional abuse and maybe that's what
they're trying to inflict on you and the
only way to move on from that is to to
walk away from it yeah and I think two
things on that too is I would just
encourage Danielle to have compassion
both for herself and then for the other
person because like you said they may be
struggling with some things that are not
on the surface
at all and she's probably feeling I get
from that like if if she just got
ghosted on and the person's not talking
to her anymore like she maybe feels hurt
and scared and maybe wondering what that
says about her right yeah um but she can
be in a position where she can just have
a lot of compassion for herself and then
maybe use that as kind of a constructive
way not that she did anything wrong to
encourage this person's behavior but how
can she make herself feel even better
and rise up and go no how can I become
an even better person where I would
never be in a situation where I would do
that to someone else and then also how
can I have compassion for this person
because they're obviously going through
some [ __ ] to to end a relationship in
this way yeah I think showing
forgiveness for someone that's wrong to
you that's like one of the most
effective ways of getting closure now
getting to that forgiveness point like
to actually feel that forgiveness it's a
lot of work oh yeah but like if you can
actually forgive someone that has
wronged you that is especially in this
situation with Danielle I mean that
might give her the closer closure or at
least start to give her some of the
closure that she's really looking for I
think that when I was ghosted part of
the reason he actually I'm not saying
this about Danielle part of it was my
fault and it was a response to something
that I did where I was like hey I need I
need some space I need I need some
distance right now like I'm no longer
feeling like I'm growing in this
relationship and so I think it'd be a
good idea for us to not communicate for
a few weeks so I can try to figure this
out you know and and I was being a bit
wishy-washy about the about the whole
scenario and and I think it was her way
to regain control and so quite often a
situation like this is is someone saying
I'm feeling powerless so maybe your
other the other person unbeknownst to
you they are just feeling like they've
lost all the power in the relationship
and and the power dynamic has tilted so
far one other way the way for me to get
power back is to tilt it back by by not
responding now now Danielle for you to
get your own power back not not to use
it as leverage against the other person
but so you no longer feel like like
you're powerless is to acknowledge the
fact that you're not communicating right
now
and to move on to stop the communication
altogether because that is how you're
going to get some of that that that
power back and then she asked about
creating she asked about how do I let go
of these these old memories the best way
is to create new memories and that that
may mean with other people it may mean
by yourself it may mean waiting a while
to date and just having great
friendships with people it may mean
trying dating out again depending on
where you are in in in your comfort
level with that but but creating any
kind of new memories is going to help
you create that necessary distance so
that you're not going to lose the old
memories necessarily they're just not no
longer gonna be in the before ground of
your reer of yes that's a beautiful
thing I want to just hover on that for a
second um when my former partner and I
consciously uncoupled so such a like a
crazy weird sentence but when we decided
to not be together anymore she wrote
this amazing post on one of her social
media feeds where I had a photo of us
this is a this is like a month after we
we ended it and she had a sentence in
there
that I think it said I'm not gonna act
as if we didn't live together for 10
years
I'm not going to delete all the photos
of us I'm not gonna burn any notes or
memories and what I liked about that is
you can go create new memories but it's
not like you have to like shove all
these other ones in a closet where you
don't think about them ever again you
can be in a position where you can think
about the good times and the bad times
and then learn something from them and
then go create those new memories while
still kind of not holding on to the old
ones but giving them the respect that
they're due at the same time and then
being like okay I don't need you right
now
social media has a way of tethering us
to the past in a way yeah and sometimes
it's really productive even if it's for
a temporary period of time to unfollow
that that person on unfriend or whatever
so you don't say tethered to those old
memories and yeah it's it's not about
having to tear everything down if you
want to keep old letters or whatever I I
don't necessarily encourage that because
I don't like toll down the things that
are no longer useful or or joyous to me
but
Minh to get rid of them so they're not a
constant reminder of what the past we
get rid of them in a way that maybe if
you're still you're scanning one thing
that I've done in the past you have scan
old photos whatever you have them sort
of in the cloud but you don't have to
have that eight-by-ten of Nate and his
former partner displayed in the living
room I wasn't when your next date comes
I would say that what I did just
speaking personally is I went through I
I look at my photos on my phone as a
curated album so I'm very particular
with like what's on my camera roll on my
phone I only maybe have 150 to 200
photos on there but every time I look at
a photo it just fills me with this like
gratitude or this memory or whatever so
I want every photo to feel that way so I
went through after we ended the
relationship and I said like internally
like which photos of her and I or of her
bring me joy still even though it's a
month and a half later and I a couple of
them and I love them and I know the next
person that I'm with that they're going
through my phone like they have to be
totally comfortable with me having other
friends and people in my life even if we
were romantically involved like in my
photo stream still well I love that man
so this can translate to Danielle I mean
she has to ask herself why does she want
to hold onto these memories it's because
it brings her joy it's because it brings
her happiness and she has this person
who left and just you know was was gone
like a like a ship in the night and she
wants to remember that person or is she
still holding on to that relationship
and are these are these memories are
they reminding her of the relationship
that she's lost is it reminding her of
the closure she didn't she didn't get
that she really really wanted I mean
that's that's where cuz I think you're
both right yeah you should and should
not hold on to love letters it depends
on what what that it depends on how that
love letter is serving you I mean you
and I talked about this on the last
podcast that we recorded I guess it was
technically two podcasts ago yeah 146
but I talked about how everything we
have in our lives it is a it's it's an
extension of who we are it is a tool
all the things not just the the literal
things but the relationships they are
all extensions of ourselves and you know
Daniel you've got to look in the mirror
and say what are these memories what are
these letters what are these pictures
what are these memorabilia pieces what
are they doing for me how are they
serving my life what how is this an
extension of me what what are those
memories what are they representing to
other people so yeah I just think if she
can kind of get to the to the why get to
the root of it then at least she can
kind of gain some leverage to maybe try
and get rid of this stuff but I'll tell
you what man no matter what do ghosting
is one of the most cowardly forms of
communication yeah I mean it is because
ghosting is not simply not talking to
someone ghosting is is not talking to
someone specifically when you know
they're looking for a response back
right but but you go back to Nate's
point you still have to have compassion
for that person because maybe they're
going through so of course of course
maybe they were hurt in some way by you
that you don't even realize yeah what I
guess what I'm getting at is is that
when I think about the relationships in
my life if I had people in my life who
were ghosting me on a regular basis
those aren't relationships that I'd want
to have in my life doesn't mean that
that person's bad doesn't mean that I
don't have compassion for that person
right but I really really would go out
of my way to not build a deep
relationship with someone who chose that
form of communication you'd rather
allocate your time and your resources
toward other people who aren't gonna
treat you like that yeah absolutely so
like Danielle has to ask herself like
does she really want to remember someone
who has ghosted her but the thing about
ghosting is it is it's one of the most
disrespectful it's worse than cursing
someone out sometimes sometimes yeah I
mean but sometimes it could be also be
more respectful because if if he knows
like he has the he'd he is just terrible
self control self discipline he's gonna
be abusive to her in some way maybe this
is the way for him to be respectful even
though it you're right is totally
different back for what's immature [ __ ]
and to not have this conversation right
because Danielle doesn't know why like
she's an
position right now where she has to
decide why for herself but she doesn't
know the reason because this person is
no longer talking to her and as it
disappeared off the face of the earth so
NASA like come up with a reason yeah and
it and I feel like it should probably be
a reason that serves her yeah no matter
what she has to create some sort of a
narrative overlay as us so Danielle you
can beat yourself up over this that's
the wrong thing to do but you can go
back and say okay what what worked with
this were we friends were we actually
friends that we have the same values
with the memories that we created
together over however long that we were
together
how are those gonna serve me going
forward and when you're creating these
these new memories the thing I'm going
to encourage Danielle to do is to follow
her curiosity and her curiosity that's
in line with her values we just talked
about values a moment ago you're gonna
be curious that to have new experiences
without this person what are you curious
about what what are you what do you want
to accomplish what do you want to try
out following that curiosity gonna
you're gonna lead down several different
paths that might be dead ends but it's
going to distance you even though those
paths but they'll fork off in two
different paths and that will distance
you from what seems to be a pretty
negative or into a negative relationship
yeah I will I will say sometimes just
going back to coming up with the reason
that serves her I totally agree with
that I think sometimes too though it's
it's relieving to say I don't know like
there are there are so many
relationships that I have in my life I
don't know why people act the way they
act especially in my family I don't
understand it and me being able to lay
my head on my pillow at night and
although all these you know chaotic
interactions or or actions that go
through my head it feels really good to
say you know what like I don't
understand and that's okay yes like I
don't have to understand in order for me
to live a meaningful life I don't have
to understand in order for me to move on
in Danielle Daniel you gotta move on if
you don't move on from this relationship
the next relationship that she gets into
it's it's she's not gonna be able to
give 100% to that relationship it's
going to
start that relationship off on the wrong
foot and it will just severely hurt the
next romantic relationship she moves
into if she does not let go of this one
she may be in a position where the
person that ghosted her she has to
assume will probably never come back
into her life but you never know like
when you were saying I agree she has to
she had she has to assume that and which
means that closure is not gonna come
from outside it has to come from her
yeah and so she has to figure out a way
for to close it on her own yes my
favorite David Foster Wallace quote
we've talked about a few times on the
podcast but it it is very relevant for
this one it's from his book Infinite
Jest everything I've ever let go of has
claw marks on it and I think we can
decide to let go before we're late
because really that's not letting go if
you're leaving claw marks it means
you're hanging on until you fall off and
the lesson to learn there is sometimes
think and here's another lesson from
that from that book in particular like
the end of that book sort of trails off
and you're not you can you can figure
out there's maybe four or five different
potential endings to that and as a
reader the real payoff is you figuring
out what what it what actually happened
here sometimes some things resolve sort
of to the right of the frame and you
don't get to actually see it and that's
what's happening exactly what Danielle's
relationship like there's going to be a
resolution here and even the ear resolve
ability of this of the ghost thing is in
and of itself a resolution and so
speaking of books I want to give away a
couple books a Kristiana who asked the
question earlier about how do I move on
from a relationship and still be friends
well I want to send you a copy of our
book everything that remains it's my
favorite thing that we've ever written
but one of those relationships that I
write about in that book was was my
marriage and ending and moving on from
that and now Kerry and I my former
spouse are much better friends we were
friends we were married we're better
friends now than we were that I've never
seen her so happy
you mean without me exactly yeah
but part of that mint like okay we are
we we are actually better as friends and
of course there was a distance there
going from that marriage we had to have
the time apart but we knew that we loved
each other but we weren't in love right
and and we also didn't share the same
values necessarily the same goals and
and you know she's remarried she has
four kids and and and a totally
different life but she got she got to go
down the path she wanted to go and I got
to go down a separate path the path I
wanted to go and if we would have stayed
together one of two things would have
happened she would have dragged me down
that path and I would have been unhappy
I would have been unsatisfied and or I
would have dragged her down my path and
she would have been unhappy unsatisfied
unfulfilled with that life and so we
wrote about that and everything that
remains podcast Shawn if you could reach
out to Christiana and send her a audio
book version if you like our podcast
you'll probably like the audiobook
version of that or the book book version
or the eBook version and then for
Danielle we talked about values and
pursuing your curiosity based on your
values well in order to do that you have
to know what your values are so Ryan and
I wrote our first book it's called
minimalism live a meaningful life and it
talks about the five fundamental values
that everyone I believe everyone has
these five values and you layer your
different values on top of those so get
really clear on what your values are
it's called minimalism live a meaningful
life you'll reach out to Danielle and
give her a copy of that book either the
audio book or the book book or the
e-book
I'm sure she'll find some value in that
all right you all we'd love to hear what
you have to say so if you have a comment
or a tip about breakups including advice
for any of the callers today then leave
us a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists com where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
episode episode and Stacey however you
want potato potato no one actually says
potato I mean out in this country at
least alright and I don't think anyone
says episode yeah
you know and stay tuned to the end of
this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips now for some reason
that sounds like like a Canadian accent
but no Canadians is a pursued yeah hey
don't offend our Canadian Ontarians in
my job I have love for them in their
weird use of the word letter you write
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
we're on Twitter Facebook and Instagram
at the minimalists or at the Nate green
oh and we're gonna graze at the earth ah
yes during tomato potato during the
lightning round Ryan and I each do our
best to answer every question was just a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share I'll put the answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our quotes in one
place minimal maxims comm Ryan yes it's
time for our first question our first
question is from Dimitri
if the breakup was my fault how can I
start to forgive myself so I'm gonna
talk about this so here's my pithy
answer so Nate if you don't have pithy
answers right away don't worry we'll
just monitor on a bit and then we'll
wrap it up with a pithy bouquet good
because you have way more practice at
this than I do well so I'd like a week
to prepare for this too so again so so
my short answer is before you can
forgive you must understand who who
you're forgiving and who the forgiving
is for so I think sometimes the your
forgiving this this other person for
what they've done but quite often you're
doing that because you forgive for
yourself you don't even have to forgive
them publicly or forgive them in person
in order to forgive someone sometimes
you just have to forgive in order to to
move on the other thing that I'll say
here is every breakup is partially your
fault now this isn't me victim blaming
but it's also partially the other
person's fault because every coupling
the unless there's two men unless there
was coercion involved it took two people
to be in that relationship and so if you
decided unless you were coerced into
being into it if you decided to be in a
relationship then that was your decision
take ownership for that that decision
even if it wasn't your fault that there
was a breakup just taking responsibility
for being there and most important
taking responsibility for the forgiving
it is important to forgive the other
person even if they wronged you even
though they were in the wrong then
although obviously this question is a
little bit different Dimitra saying it
was his fault
and then how do I forgive myself well if
you were in the wrong it's most
important to forgive yourself in order
to move on the other thing I'll say is
it's important to make amends yeah
however you can to the best of your
ability maybe that person is ghosting
him now and he's not able to to make
amends but you can you can go out of
your way to try to make amends with that
person and and and and say you're sorry
so that eventually you can forgive
yourself yeah my pithy answer is this
the best way to forgive yourself is to
consistently be honest and freely
forgive no matter how uncomfortable it
is so I know for me when I think about
how I've wronged people in the past
serves people in my life now who I have
definitely wronged the way that I
forgive myself as I go out of my way to
show that other person how how dedicated
I am how supportive I am how respectful
I am to that person now now maybe
particular for Dmitri or they can't go
out of their way and be in show support
for the person that they've wronged but
what they can do is every other
relationship every single relationship
in their life every other relationship
besides this person they broke up with
then go out of their way to be extremely
honest and to forgive freely they can
pay it forward in a way yeah existing
and future is gonna be my response was
even if you can't make amends to the
person that you feel feel like you
wronged you can start to live
differently starting right now yes you
can decide this is why it end
this was my part in it and you can
identify a couple of habits maybe and
you can think to yourself how do I deal
with this now and maybe the next
interaction you have with another person
you do the opposite of what you did in
the previous relationship yeah I think
the pithy answer there Shawn is the
rearview does not equal the horizon oh
you're good at this but I mean really
because what happens is we constantly
look back back back back I'm staring at
this rearview mirror and of course if
you carry that metaphor forward you
eventually crash if you if you're just
if you're just looking at the past
you're looking at what's going on behind
you you put it's also important to
glance back and say okay that's what
what happened back there yeah how can I
carry that forward how does it help
determine my my path forward want to go
with the car analogy like you're looking
back it's like what what might be coming
up that I need to look out for
yeah it's yeah absolutely ma'am all
right our next question is from Michael
during a breakup when both partners are
minimalists and value heavily the items
they have brought into their joint life
how do they divide those items up yeah
so so so I mean Nate you went through
this recently I tell you what I did with
my marriage in particular I uh I just
don't carry hey whatever whatever you
want you can have she got the dog she
got both cats still has a lot of force
those onto her they were her cats not
mine but the my pithy answer which
really sums up how I feel about this is
you must be willing to let go of
anything to regain everything the truth
man that's like the biggest superpower
we have right now yeah oh yeah yeah the
power to detach like that's that is uh I
mean I don't have any relationships now
that I can think of that I'd like I'm
trying to forget but like having that
power if they're if that ever comes a
time like I will be able to face that
stuff and those little pieces of
memorabilia the same stuff that I think
it was Adrian was talking about holding
on to it's it's uh it's a great power to
have yeah become one attached it's the
it's the unclaimed from stuff right yeah
was daniella Soriano yeah it's that
unclicking from from from the stuff
because what's gonna happen otherwise
you yeah now you're saying these things
are valuable to you but also put it in
perspective Michael there's still just
things yeah and I we were talking about
this very beginning the episode like I
really like everything that is in my
apartment now like I feel good about the
stuff that's there but if Bex and I were
to decide hey we want to go separate
directions I would I would approach it
the same way I would say hey what what's
what's gonna be valuable for you or what
should we do with it yeah and the way
that the way that my former partner and
I decided to do things is I mean one I'm
leaving to go travel around for a while
and so it made the most sense for me to
tell her take whatever you think is
valuable that you want because I'm
probably going to sell it or give it
away anyway but I also feel like this is
a amazing opportunity to kind of
recommit to figuring out what is
valuable in your life that you have
right now so maybe it's a new way of
like looking at all the things that you
brought into the relationship together
and say okay does this still bring value
into my life considering what my life is
going to look like now that we're not
together yeah and it may make sense even
though it added value before exactly
makes sense to let it go because it's
not we're gonna be part of your future
life accurately right and there's and
there may be a strong like emotional
component of that which is not that I
need to go get new and better and
different stuff but this was part of
this relationship and I can leave this
and I can start fresh on my own with
things that add a lot of value to my
life whether or not that's physical
things or not becomes a symbol of
letting go because never let go of the
things that you you brought together
because maybe you got a eight out of ten
value up from it before and so it made
sense the whole on - but now going
forward just think of some value from it
like oh yeah it's the four out of ten
now okay then then maybe someone else if
I'd if I get rid of it I sell it to
someone maybe someone else can get that
eight out of ten value from it once
again yeah my short answer is this if
you can't handle the [ __ ] you're Barry
in hire a professional [ __ ] cleaner you
know I mean yeah I mean this is this is
for uh this is for you know those
extreme cases where yeah maybe you don't
have a lot of stuff but you're kind of
fighting over what what you get I mean
sometimes you got a hire a mediator to
kind of help divide the stuff up or you
know what like I wouldn't I wouldn't
feel bad recommending that they reach
out to a friend to help mediate - I mean
if they got someone that they both trust
and can kind of sit there and help them
divide stuff up equally then then yeah
you might need to bring in a third party
but I know sometimes - like it's it's
embarrassing to like go and ask like to
hire a mediator - I know for me like
hiring well I guess like as I'm I'm like
pretty wear my heart on my sleeve type
of person like I'm not too embarrassed
about like seeing a therapist or
anything but a lot of people they're
embarrassed like especially in certain
cultures like that it is a very
humiliating embarrassing thing and that
culture to like go out and ask for
professional help when there's
vulnerability is weak yeah absolutely
culture yeah it's you bring that up I
think that helps provide additional
perspective right seeing a mediator or a
therapist or
couples counselor or whomever even at
the end of a relationship can be useful
I know Kari and I my former spouse we we
went through couples counseling at the
end of it to try to maybe look forward
to like okay what did I what I learned
from this because you're uncoupling we
were together for eight years
you're uncoupling a lot and and I can't
work through it all nestled on my own
and is putting it into perspective
because the important things are rarely
things and and you can tweet that
podcast Sean in fact I would argue
they're they're pretty much never things
I mean our documentary is called
minimalism a documentary about the
important things because it has nothing
to do with the physical things the
things in our life these things that
Michael and and his former spouse or
partner that they brought in their lives
they brought those in hopefully to
augment their life to amplify their
experience of life to enhance their life
not because they were important but
because that life is important and you
want to be able to augment that
accordingly
one thing that we my former partner and
I always kind of joked about was how we
wanted to write a relationship book
because we thought we were doing like
and we were we were doing a I think I
think we both agreed that we had a
wonderful relationship and the last time
I saw her she kind of joked but I think
there's a little seriousness in there
too she said we should give it a year
and maybe write that relationship book
and I was like ooh that's a good idea
because we can still kind of be creative
together and help people so yeah I don't
know that we'll ever pan out but I've
never heard of a relationship book from
people that ended a relationship no it's
you were functionally divorced yeah and
and being able to recover from that and
I think the way to think about that is
you you're still you're moving on from
this thing and you can be grateful for
though that decade together or that
month together or that weekend together
with that relationship it's not
necessarily a breakup and I hope that's
what people get from this episode is
you're not necessarily breaking up you
don't have to break up there doesn't
have to be something that's broken you
might get there and it's already broken
and you can't fix it but they're gonna
be future relationships that may not
last forever and instead of looking at
it as a failure
look at it as a 10-year success look at
it as a one-year success a six-month
success some of the best relationships
I've ever had ended but all good things
come to an end eventually on a long
enough timeline
everything is ephemeral we're all going
to die it's going to end at some point
whether that's during your lifetime or
after your life and acknowledging that
makes you appreciate that impermanence
it absolutely does I can't tell you do
like the first time I because you know
we all know that no one makes it out of
here alive mmm like I mean that through
the history of all the history books
like no one has made it out of here
alive and once I like kind of accepted
that it is a it's a freeing it's a very
freeing feeling but yes it I can't agree
with you more do you like it totally
helps you embrace the ephemerality and
appreciate it and what you do is you and
this
the thing that I struggle with but I
always try to remind myself is to not
grasp or try to be attached to something
that cling to something like leaving
claw marks on everything and then to not
try to push everything else away to
because everything is impermanent
everything is going to change so if you
just kind of let life keep lifing it'll
just take care of itself
tweet that if you let life keep it I
think it'll take care of itself
PS gentlemen we have one more question
DJ asks what do you do with all the old
photos from past relationships so wait
this question is literally worded what
do you do with all the old photos from
my past relationships
well Josh let me tell you what I should
do with them before we get into that
though so I'm looking I'm looking
forward to answering this question
because I think all three of us might
have a slightly different way that we
curate photos from old relationships or
let go of them or not let go of them but
if you'd like to hear our answer to that
question you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalists private podcast feed it's
available exclusively to our patreon
supporters so if you want to support our
show and keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our monthly ask the
minimalists anything episodes unreleased
recordings of our live events and the
entire back catalogue of past private
episodes once you become a supporter
you'll also receive a personal link to
our private podcast feeds so that it
plays in your normal podcast player and
as a patreon supporter you also receive
access to our monthly live stream videos
as well as first access to tickets to
all of our live events before those
tickets are available to the general
public
you can find all the details and all the
good stuff over at the minimalists comm
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode
[Music]
if I were in a position where like we
just didn't hang out that much for
whatever reason I would still keep a
photo of all of us yeah that's a good
memory because I get to look back at
that and I want that emotional Joel I
got and kind of like put myself back in
that time frame and think wow this was a
period of my life that was beautiful and
challenging and I just I just like
having that memory I like I like having
that a jolt of memory again
well what I'm hearing you say is that
you you are choosing to respect the past
relationship absolutely I wasn't trying
to act like it didn't exist or didn't
happen right like you want to respect
its existence and you want to you know
pay tribute to it in some way I like to
honor it maybe maybe that's a better way
of saying it that's a beautiful way of
saying yeah I feel like so I only kept a
couple of photos of her and her and I
but I look at them and it makes me smile
and it's honoring the relationship that
we had
[Music]
okay now it's time for our added-value
portion in the show this is where we
each talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently so I already
mentioned Collin Wright's book but since
we're talking about breakups or
relationships he he really talks about
moving forward in a way moving forward
in your current relationship that makes
it so that even when you uncouple it's
not a breakup it doesn't feel like a
break it's the whether it's the campsite
rule or the I'll tell you policy or a
bunch of other policies that are useful
not in just intimate relationships but
everyday relationships so Jordan if
folks are watching this on YouTube we'll
put the book cover right here somewhere
of some thoughts about so yeah right
over Nate's face here some thoughts
about relationships from our good friend
Colin right also when we're talking
about relationships I watched this this
YouTube interview with Will Smith and
some good videos out there yeah I mean
he's been he's really embraced social
media recently and he did a interview on
the rap radar podcast with Elliott
Wilson and B dot and the thing that I
found compelling it's only on title the
podcast is the the streaming service
title but they do YouTube videos as well
so I watched it on on YouTube and he
talked about his relationship with with
Jada and they've been together for 20
years and the thing he talked about is
which I found really fascinating they've
got to this point in their relationship
or he's like she could literally do
anything and there's nothing that she
could do that I wouldn't forgive her and
find a way to be able to move forward
and yeah and and he said after 17 years
or they hit this low point in the
relationship 17 years in they went to go
see this sort of therapist type person a
mediator type person a friend of theirs
and this old wise woman and and she
asked she asked Will Smith so how long
have you two been together and you're
going through these problems now and
he's like I always been to go for 17
years she goes oh honey you barely know
each other and it's like we've talked
the past few episodes about perspectives
that is that perspective shift or it's
like yeah imagine that like I feel like
I've I've been with backseat for three
nights
I feel like I've been with her for a
whole lifetime yeah but maybe we don't
actually even know each other the same
way we will at 10 years in I mean think
about this with you you just got a
10-year relationship three years in was
a different relationship from from what
it was recently for a couple reasons one
is you continue to grow as a person you
get older you mature you your values
shift or you better understand your
beliefs shift your desires shift your
objective or goals and life shift you
become a different person the other
person becomes a different person and
you get to know each other together in a
way mm-hmm yeah I feel like I'm still
learning to get getting to know Mariah I
mean it's it's it's awesome though it's
beautiful because you want to still have
a little bit of mystery coz you still
want to be able to be surprised by the
other person in a positive way yeah
absolutely yeah and one of the things
that helps me out with that is distance
yeah Beck's and I aren't always in the
same city because of some Jia Jia
graphical constraints and so we are only
together about half the time and which
is great for me because I'm an injury
would not what that would not work for
Ryan I don't as long as I couldn't date
someone in Irvine alone let alone
keeping a relationship going across
States so when we lived in Montana I had
made an accidental rule it just happened
this way like Beck's was the only person
in Montana that I dated who lived within
the boundaries of the state line yeah
and that worked out better for me
because I need so much alone time what
I've realized what back said we were
forced into this this weird sort of
scenario where we're not together all
the time but that makes the time we're
together so much better I feel I feel
like when we're out together in public
like like I never take her for granted
because I think think about if you go
eat at the best restaurant in LA every
single night for dinner it's gonna be
good and then it's gonna start to be
less good and you're gonna start to take
it for granted yeah so I've been trying
to find ways in my life to love the
things that I love and to give myself a
little bit of space from them on purpose
that way I can come back to them with
the full like acknowledgment that these
are beautiful things and be
people I'm trying to figure out like why
or how I'm able to wake up every morning
and feel more excited about my
relationship with Mariah and I'm like I
don't know what it is I mean we're just
such a good match like maybe that's what
it is but like it is one thing that like
going with a restaurant analogy it's
like I eat there and it gets better and
better and better I'm like oh my god I
didn't know you guys had this in the
back said that's right I didn't know you
were keeping that back there hey where
are you looking so I think with that
that's like if you were to go to the
same restaurant every day though and it
kept in it literally kept getting better
because your relationship continues to
improve as opposed to like I eat at
Chipotle all the time and it's pretty
much always the same thankfully I don't
go to any ones that have give people
food poisoning but you know I I think
that like that can happen in a
relationship - we're all of a sudden it
gets poisoned and then then if you that
happens enough all of a sudden you're
like I got to get out of this I can't
continue to go down this path and so my
added value this week is besides Colin's
book is we'll put a link to that that
rap radar video with Will Smith where
it's an hour long conversation a lot of
that has to do with his marriage and it
was it was really inspiring to me Ryan
what's been adding value to your life I
see that I stole your added value I'm
sorry uh yeah man you know that Jack
Harlow album just came out you're the
one to let me know about it it's pretty
good I mean like I don't know why but
every time like I'll have an album that
I really really love yeah a good example
to be Andrew Belle's a black bear yeah
great album when his following out when
we came out yeah I was not nearly as in
love with it I was like man this is not
black diary yeah okay like man like dive
deep this is not as good as black bear
and then eventually like I really really
ended up loving dive deep just as much
as I liked black bear I'm in that
interim stage right now with this with
loose with Jack Hartley's new album this
is like I'm someone can maybe leave this
in the YouTube comments for us there's
actually a psychological term for this
where you are
to a some sort of creation it could be
an album for me Jonathan Franzen's books
stand out to me so I read freedom before
I read the corrections and I know other
people who read the corrections before
the read freedom because that's the
order they came out in and whichever
book you read first is the one you tend
to grab it's your favorite of his book
it's the same thing with when they do
like the hey the coke versus Pepsi test
like whatever whichever brand they're
trying to get you to favor they give you
that one first you try this because
regardless like what you test after it's
gonna be either sweeter or it's gonna be
less sweet but regardless it's like that
first one that you taste like ninety
percent of the time people pick the
first thing that they taste like
establishes your palate in a way so you
established your musical palette with
Jack Harlow's previous album which is
called gazebo and it's amazing it's an
out of ten there's new ones called loose
yeah and it's about seven a ton for me
right now I think it will get to that
ten on a ten point I think you listen to
if every song on there was like the
first song it would definitely be a ten
out of ten but there there are are just
bits of it like it's it has you know for
lack of a better term it has a
particular vibe that's different from
the vibe on his first album yeah and it
has been growing on me I've been playing
it a lot this this past week I'm really
diggin it's good
all right cool let's move on the right
here right now so where we talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist I don't have really have a
whole lot to talk why do you have
dodgeball finals on here tonight
dude they don't care about our lame-ass
dodgeball team no one cares about that I
don't even care about that I was gonna
ask you I haven't found a babysitter for
Ella because our babysitter is out of
town should I bring her there tonight
yeah dude that'd be great do you think
they'd be okay with absolutely oh you're
being serious I mean there's there's a
lot it's a flights final there's a lot
of I mean it's a very it's a very riot
there's a lot of cursing and a lot of
sexual innuendos going on it's a gay
dodgeball league or like were there six
straight people there with me and Ryan
are two partners and then Matthew Vela
yeah and his fiancee Natalie okay yeah
so so we're all in this this gay
dodgeball league suite and yeah there
you're right there is a whole lot of for
not-safe-for-work con
yeah did you well it was if you already
said you're gonna be there dude like I
haven't said whether or not I'm gonna be
there I hold Alex I need to see whether
or not I know I can find a babysitter
but hopefully you make a mint it'll be
we have a chance to win it
oh really I mean we well dude it's only
like three and four years a thing dude
the final is like everyone makes it to
the finals and everyone who enters the
finals has a chance to win it all it's a
participation truth right no you do not
get that you either win or you get a
scolding from our team captain Alex we
got a dodgeball we saw we saw someone
get beamed with a ball last night we
went to our first Dodgers game dude they
see they lost right no I didn't I I we
didn't get to bed like we left with what
it was like a four and a half hour game
probably right we got home at 10:30 we
left it like the sixth sixth inning yeah
yeah cuz any ellos with us so this is
her very first she was masked out like
within five minutes soon as we got the
car I got a poop and then she just see I
got a poop real bad yeah instantly was
was asleep
it was Mariah's first major league
baseball game as well yeah Ella liked it
because I mean going to the live games
things different watching on TV or or
watching a a live baseball game that's
like the you know every few seconds
let's go Dodgers like people like it's
the the it's like it's true participants
page experience yeah yeah I had no idea
was going on but she loved it she was so
excited it was able to participate the
wave dude and yeah I mean we were on the
parking lot and I was like let's go oh
and then she was like clapping to the
beat of let's yeah it was so good
Ryan you moving into your new apartment
we're gonna do some it's awesome yeah
we're gonna do some living room
conversation way smaller but that's okay
because I'm a minimalist yeah
my favorite compliment is we had people
over for dinner and one of my friends
was like she was like you just moved in
like you just had all your stuff put
here yesterday I'm like yeah she was
like how do you have it so put together
already I'm like when you don't own a
lot of stuff doesn't take you a whole
lot of time to put your place together
no we're loving it man it's smaller it's
one better
bath can't really host as many guests
but like we had Sean mihalick over the
weekend he was there just sleeping on
her couch so we can still you know have
have a guest yeah for I can work for
sure small yeah for a short period of
time dude
and it's nice because it staves off the
the one-month sort of guests and I mean
although I know for me like that would
be that would be exceptionally difficult
I think the only person I've ever had
stay over at my house is Nate and and
his partner and now again yeah I think I
think that's it
Bex told you but I'm moving in next
month nice okay whatever you in Bexar it
I'm sure she'd be happy bedroom I'll
film it if you'd like oh you definitely
don't want to see that film speaking of
Nate being naked in my bedroom oh great
we've raised $40,000 so far for the gym
city market oh my god that is incredible
and so I want to say thanks we're still
trying to get to $100,000 so Ryan and I
are from Dayton Ohio one of the largest
food deserts in the country is in West
Dayton and we're trying to help them
build a grocery store there's not a
single grocery store on the entire west
side of Dayton oh my god and the last
one closed in 2008 2009 and and now they
don't have access to I mean they've
access to food like food and quotes
right cheetos at the liquor store not
actual food not nutrition yeah and so
we're trying to help out and if you can
help us out if you want to do one thing
for us if you want to support in one way
we can really use your help go Ryan and
I are donating twenty thousand of our
own dollars and we need you all to help
make up the difference there there's
this forty K and glue the twenty we're
given yes okay yes it does and so we're
still we're still sixty thousand dollars
away get in there yeah I'm straight now
yeah we're trying to get there by the
end of the year we'll give them enough
funds I just just talked to them this
week and they're they're really excited
with the amount of money we've been able
to raise so far but I've told them you
obviously we want to get to that fold at
four hundred thousand mark so we can get
this up and running for
if you're interested in that just go to
the minimalists comm slash Dayton and
let's get to $100,000 there I could talk
about what's going on in YouTube but we
got a whole bunch of stuff going on
YouTube bunch of new living room
conversations with guests including Nate
our friend shell mihalick did a living
room conversation we're gonna do some
living room conversations over at and
Ryan's place as well oh we had dr. Ryan
green on there oh and if you want access
to our podcast show notes you can sign
up for our emails over at the
minimalists comm just go over there and
type your email at the top Sean will
send you a can of spam immediately you
get one free can of spam with every sign
up but that's the only spam will send
you see story details spam not including
additional purchase of spam required you
had the documentary oh yeah as a bullet
on here so so Matt's deadline for a
first cut was one yesterday tomorrow
tomorrow okay and then it's being sent
off for the soundtrack yeah I had dinner
with him last night he was he wasn't
working on the film that's no very
distracting yeah What did he say about
it
not all good things no I'm kidding no he
seems really excited about it he says
he's working a lot right now oh yeah I
thought that he's excited for the
project yeah I'm excited i watch it yeah
me too this last week I know he's been
working hard to get edits and everything
in there and yes I don't know how the
hell he makes Josh and I look good like
it's funny what people don't know is
that so when you know in order to get
like an hour of good video with Josh now
you got to have about 2,000 hours the
same thing with the same thing with
photos to get a good picture of the two
of us you've got to take about 200
photos and then he get like one good one
what happens usually I look like I have
some weird look on my face and Ryan has
his eyes closed in every photo I don't
know how eyes closed that was not a
minimal maxim all right Joe here are
some comments and tips from our
listeners hi this is Justin Seattle
I recently had a breakup with a
boyfriend and and this is more of a
comment than a question I had just found
that being in situations that are not
the right situations to be in get family
friends or a boyfriend sometimes to have
us do things that are not so good and
sometimes that means behind things or
more difficult than I an experience sort
of things and I have found this was my
breakup things just really don't matter
and life is actually pretty awesome and
experience does mean more and more and I
just think that sometimes and don't know
about that Merman there is something
that isn't the right place so keep an
eye I guess and my idea is keeping an
eye on what are you doing things that
aren't healthy and what are you doing
other things in your private time that
aren't optimal and then stop and think
what surrounds you and what makes you do
hi this is Julie Barda I'm in Redlands
California and I have been recently
binge listening to your podcasts I
wanted to share some comments on
collecting items just in case I loved
some of the things that you say but I
wanted to also add saving items for
special occasions I'm very guilty of
hoarding items for a special occasion
and several times I found that those
items go bad and so I am trying to
change my outlook and I was cleaning out
my covers I found a couple bottles of
expensive wine I was saving for a
special occasion
and I recently had some friends who just
popped in for dinner so I decided to
call it the wine and what was just a
normal dinner with friends turned into a
special occasion where we had great
conversations and we enjoyed this great
wine that had been in my cupboard for
two years so something to think about is
instead of saving things for a special
occasion
taking something every day and turning
it into something
special and save those items use them up
hi Josh Ryan my name is Justin I live in
Cleveland while I recently went to a
breakup on July third was a girl that I
was really icy madly in love she was a
minimalist as well um I took a bit hard
one thing that I found that I was
lacking in this relationship was that I
wasn't considerably one whole person I
needed her to support my happiness which
is a big reason why relationship failed
following that relationship I decided to
look at other means to build my own you
know self and integrity off of different
aspects like working out exercise I
recently took up yoga so I figured
that'd be something that could be
beneficial for other people are going
through a hard time if they look at
themselves introspectively figure out
what they can do to make themselves a
better person through this through a
break alright show that's almost it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalists give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm we're
especially looking for questions about
discipline about spouses and about
preferences or personalities maybe
another way to talk about that we're
gonna Ryan and I are gonna go through
our own myers-briggs test and talk about
that also gonna take that what's was
Graham yeah is that we is that what is
that that's the new test yeah like the
myers-briggs like that's what like old
people are using
yeah they any Oh Graham Enneagram how do
you spell it
and okay so any Oh Graham Instagram yeah
any Oh Graham that's what the cool kids
are doing India ground one of you go and
then oh just any Graham Enneagram any uh
Graham yeah oh yeah so we're gonna talk
about that so first we're gonna figure
I'm gonna figure out how to say the word
now then I'm gonna take the time that
was tiring yeah
I want to thank Nate Greene for being
here today Nate I really appreciate the
conversation thank you for being
honorable thank you for being open thank
you guys for having me thank you I don't
know if I could have been a podcast six
weeks after after having a conscious
what is it called again conscious
uncoupling later having a conscious
uncoupling and talking about openly my
yeah you're awesome dude my life's
beautiful and her
is going really well and I mean
hopefully this helps some people right
so yeah thanks for having me on here I
really appreciate heading I think that
term conscious uncoupling is way better
than an unconscious coupling which is
usually what happens right I don't know
nothing tonight it's just sort of what
happens it's like oh we we met each
other at a bar or on tinder or something
almost say and now we're dating and I
don't feel good about this thing and
it's an unconscious coupling I prefer I
prefer the the hospital at ER bling ends
yeah all right so uh what else oh yeah
if you all leave here today if you all
though if you want to follow Nate it's
Nate green org or @v Nate green on
Twitter and if you all leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
thank you bye oh and minimus